I talk about is the notation so
somebody's you'll see when you're doing
compositions of functions this F of G of
X see this little circle here sometimes
students mistakenly think this is like a
zero or a multiplication symbol so you
want to make that mistake all this
represents here is that we're taking the
G function and we're putting it into the
F function so I oftentimes like to take
this and rewrite it as f of G of X
meaning that we're starting from the
inside just like we do with an order of
operations and we work our way out okay
so basically way these functions are
working is you're starting on the inside
your say I'm going to put my X right
into my G function I'm gonna get an
answer okay the output and then I'm
going to take that output and I'm gonna
put it into my F function and I'm going
to get our final result so it's
basically like a two-step process so the
wave functions work again is that
whatever's in parenthesis say for
example we're working with this f of X
function equals two X minus three
whatever's here in parentheses that's
going to go in place of X on the right
side of the equation so it's just a
substitution so here we're putting three
in place of X and then we can simplify
that six minus three which is three and
we got it so let's get into some
examples and I'll show you how this
works
so for example number one we've got F of
G of two okay so what we do with this
one this is a numerical example some of
these other ones that just involve
variables but what we're going to do is
we're going to rewrite this we're going
to think of this as f of G of 2 we're
going to start on the inside go to our G
function and again remember whatever is
in the parenthesis that goes in for X on
the right so this is actually going to
be 2 squared minus 1 which is 4 minus 1
is 3 so now this is equal to 3 so that's
going to be F of 3 so we go to our F
function we put in 3 2 times 3 is 6
minus 3 equals 3 and we've got it so
it's just a multi-step process right
let's go to example number 2 G of H of X
again I'm going to start off and just
rewrite this a little bit differently G
of H of X and what we're going to do
here is we're gonna start on the inside
H of x equals 4 over X so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to replace H of X
with what it
that's four over X now what we're gonna
do is really go over to our G function
and again remember whatever is in
parentheses that goes in for X on the
right so that's gonna equal we're gonna
put the 4 over X in place of X this is
like our new input think of X is like
your input substitute that in we're
gonna then square it and we're gonna
subtract 1
now before I simplify oftentimes in
these problems we'll say well you know
what is the domain or what are the
restrictions on the domain
so before I simplify it just kind of
analyze and I say hmm looks like X
cannot equal 0 because we can't divide
by zero that's undefined so you might
want to state that at this point you
know X cannot equal 0 but let's simplify
so we're going to square the numerator
we're gonna square the denominator
that's 16 over x squared minus 1 and
that's your final result so now if you
wanted to find out what's G of H of 2
what you could do is you could just put
2 in place of X here in this you know
this final equation and that's going to
give you you know your end result
without having to do it in two steps
okay so we're basically finding a
formula that does that all in one one
step let's go to example number three
we've got M of f of X again I like to
rewrite this like like this I think it's
a little bit more descriptive we're
going to start on the inside f of X is
2x minus 3 so let's put that in place of
f of X now we're going to go to our M
function which is over here whatever is
in parentheses goes in place of X on the
right so what we have here is we have 3
instead of X I'm going to put 2x minus 3
in place of X so whatever's in
parentheses that's what you're putting
in place of X there and then you know we
can try to simplify this as about as far
as we can go but if you want to analyze
the domain you can see that we can't
take the square root of negative numbers
that would give us imaginary numbers so
whatever is underneath this square root
has to be greater than or equal to 0 so
let's just solve this inequality here
divide both sides by 2 and you can see
that X has to be greater than or equal
to 3 halves